[موسيقى]
لنفهم ما حدث وما سيترتب عليه دعونا نعود
بكم قليلا الى الوراء لنفهم حرب الغواصات
التي اندلعت بين حلفاء الامس خلفاء اليوم
من يقودها من يشارك فيها من استبعد منها
ولماذا وبالضمان تقرع طبولها اتفاق اوكس
كان الخطوه الاكثر مفاجاه في جهود
الولايات المتحده الامريكيه لاحتواء الصين
من خلال تحالفات متعدده
الحرب تحت سطح البحر ستكون بالتاكيد هي
ميدان الصراع المقبل وسيشهد الكثير من
المعارك العسكريه
وبالنسبه للاسطول الاسترالي فان استراليا
ترى انه من خلال تحالفاتها مع البحريه
الامريكيه والبريطانيه
ستصنع اسطولا بحريا اكبر من الاسطول الصين
[موسيقى]
تعتبر غواصه فرجينيا السلاح المفضله
للبحريه الامريكيه في مهام المحيطات
المفتوحه الحفاظ على توازن القوى داخل
المحيط الهادئ امر مهم للغايه هذه الاهميه
واضحه للولايات المتحده وكذلك لاستراليا
كونهما من قوى المحيط الهادئ نحن امام
صفقه تجاريه بحته في نهايه الامر ام اننا
امام صفقه سياسيه تمهد لنظام عالمي جديد
هناك بعض القدرات
الاصيله في الغواصات النوويه التي
بالتحديات الاساسيه المطلوبه
لمجابهه البحريه
الصينيه التي تشكل تهديدا للشركاء في
المنطقه لماذا تستعدي كانديرا بيجين
التهديدات غير المتناظره التي تشكلها
الصين بما في ذلك تهديدات سيبرانيه وغيرها
من التهديدات الاخرى دون ما كذلك نسيان
المواجهه الموجوده ما بين
الاطراف المختلفه في المياه المفتوحه
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
الى اي مدى فرنسا ستجاري الرؤيه ام انها
لانها لم تجاري هذه الرؤيه الامريكيه
فهيستبعدت ان صحى التعبير في حلف اوكوس لن
تغادر تلك المنطقه على الاطلاق الامر لا
يتعلق فقط
بالعقد او الصفقه
[موسيقى]